quick name the current MCU Avengers
lineup you can't because there really
isn't one and that's the potential
problem as the franchise chugs onward
after the surprise success of Iron Man
it's seen that the wild idea to connect
a group of superhero films together with
the goal of bringing those characters
together for a crossover might actually
work and then improbably it did for
three phases and just over a decade The
Avengers Initiative thrived saving the
Earth from numerous threats and earning
billions of dollars at the box office
birds were ice Mightiest Heroes now for
a few years now that question has had no
real answer phase four of the MCU came
and went without a proper Avengers film
many of the franchises original Stars
stepped away and the series has like
direction there's a new Captain America
a new Hawkeye and a couple new Hulks
this is my son scar
but very little connected them and man
in the WASP quanta Mania producer
Stephen Bouchard recently told inverse a
lot of phase four was about introducing
the Next Generation and introducing new
characters it was also about
experimenting and building out the
franchises streaming presence on Disney
plus that's all well and good but the
MCU has only gotten more disjointed
since Avengers end game that issue has
never been more apparent than in Quantum
Mania which was meant to kick off Phase
5 with a bang instead It suffers from
the same big problem that plagued phase
four a failure to connect to the larger
Marvel World Quantum Mania references
The Avengers constantly from the very
start the movie tries to develop
attention between Scott Lang and his
daughter Cassie based on his membership
in the superhero team I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
ouch she repeatedly chastises him for
claiming to be a hero while at the same
time ignoring all the people in the
world who need his help later on Kang
the Conqueror references or The Avengers
he's killed in alternate timelines the
title is thrown around often and whether
Claire intended wait behind it
unfortunately it's hard to know what the
word even means at this point who are
the Avengers at the start of phase five
is it the whole cause of sipping Mojitos
with his cousin or maybe some Wilson and
Bucky Barnes who spend the duration of
phase 4 trying to heal the post-blip
world without any help from their
supposed friends crossovers with huge
stars are obviously expensive and
difficult to schedule but that's hardly
an excuse for a company as massive as
Disney
every time Quantum Mania references The
Avengers it feels more like a reference
for the audience as if to say remember
those better movies the sad fact is it's
hard to conjure a complete picture of
what the Avengers or the world of the
MCU even look like at this point as the
first chapter in Phase 5 quantumania
definitely tries to plant seeds for a
new overarching storyline in the MCU
Jonathan Majors is spectacular as Kang
and he could make a great new lead
villain but the film doesn't do nearly
enough to organize a massive phase 4
leaving the future of the franchise
still somewhat in the dark when can
attacks again in 2025's Avengers the
Kang Dynasty who will face him a random
assemblage of fresh faces from Disney
plus and older stars who renewed their
Marvel contracts in Infinity War it was
exciting to see doctor strange Iron Man
and the Guardians of the Galaxy all
fighting together because they've been
on a clear Collision Course for years
and the other character relationships
were built up more gradually remember
when Hawkeye popped up in Thor Orem
Black Widow debuted in Iron Man 2. there
was a clear reason for these appearances
and they laid the groundwork for what
came later now it's all a big mess what
does Moon Knight have to say to Miss
Marvel why would Kate Bishop team up
with Xiang CHI with the title of Avenger
now lacking a clear meaning there's no
gravity pulling these disparate
characters together and not much reason
to look forward to the next big team up
maybe Cassie Lang is right maybe her dad
really isn't an Avenger anymore right
now it looks like no one is
foreign